hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to what might just
be the last episode of
five nights at freddy's vr now those
half stars wait a minute that was the
big
question about last time also what does
that button do i have no idea but
there are stars here and there are no
stars there and i'm
not 100 sure why but that
that was that wait i'm telling you that
that is that the colors are slightly
different but it's still that
so all that matters is going into the
end with a little bit of bravery a
little bit of
hutzpah i've got hutzpah i've got
bravery
i've got all the above so this is the
mama jamba
this is the big buckahoona here we go
teleport
teleport i guess this did this did take
the place of the
five nights at freddy's 4-1 but i don't
know don't be late wait what
wait i'm sorry i'm sorry what
don't don't be late what does that mean
is it still in that room oh [ __ ] okay
all right
i'm ready what do you got for me huh
fine what the [ __ ]
oh oh do you trust me
this way ah oh
oh oh i have to pick
oh where's freddy where's freddy huh
oh find me this way
do you trust me ah
yeah yeah i do i i do you know what i do
trust you
i do
i do trust you huh which in way
he's coming
[Music]
oh hi um okay hey how are you doing
whoa boy they're ready for you
[ __ ] okay um
all right interesting
not this dude all right
so all right so um
interesting very interesting i'm gonna
go
i'm gonna go this way you know just
cause for [ __ ] and giggle tools
this way huh oh frick
oh freak oh find the path
oh frick what is
are you lost a little bit yeah
a little bit this way um okay
am i lost a little bit yeah how about
this one
oh hey i found the way
i think uh
are you still coming oh so i found the
path
but not the right path hang on a second
okay you're on the way now
hey you you come come closer come close
or come
close or come closer
okay cool all right it's fine that's
fine because
that's that's fine that's nothing that
ain't nothing because there
there's something here because what if
in here there's a secret that needs to
be found
find the path you say well i'm gonna
find the path
uh-huh you can count on that there's
nothing special here i can't go back
so whoa how about this one
oh [ __ ] oh oh oh oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
oh oh [ __ ] okay well i goofed this
bigly why are you everywhere this golden
rabbit
wait a minute the wrap wait the rabbit
not this way oh
hi how are you can i help you
oh oh oh oh no no
no no
there you are okay
this uh whole episode's just gonna be
finding the jump scares well this one
remember jeremy i will not screw you
jeremy
okay so if i'm guessing this right and
if it's correct i'll just go quickly to
the other one
if i'm guessing this right if i go down
here to the n1 it's going gonna loop
back to that hallway
no [ __ ] what what that not this way
not this way oh oh god am i about to die
why am i in five nights at freddy's
hi okay um this way
that way what is why where am i then
oh sorry out of order what
nah ah no don't lie to me oh my god
oh
[Music]
favorite flavor vanilla
chocolate a lot of chocolate
i like a lot of chalk a lot i'm going to
die aren't i i don't know which way i'm
going chalk a lot
oh [ __ ] okay so we're just looping
around oh
funkalicious okay wait i'm gonna go okay
there you are
okay so this is interesting so just
the other one's like a okay that's
definitely out of order i can't go that
way again
what's this way
oh this way not great
not there not where not what
and not why great great i like great
find okay so i'm back at the beginning
very interesting okay very interesting
very interesting oh [ __ ]
okay so that's that which is fine
because if i keep going
i'm not gonna have to worry about it
right and i'm back here okay that's
extremely out of order
this is this this goes here
[Music]
[ __ ] okay god
this goes here so
great not
here not there this way what about this
one
okay i'm still alive oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
can i go there no [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] hi
hello oh [ __ ] don't like that okay uh
exit exit exit um
this one should oh
[ __ ] where is this what the hell oh my
god
oh my god four oh [ __ ] that's not good
this way
[Music]
what's happening what's happening
oh hello i'm gonna go excuse me sorry
out of order door
okay oh [ __ ] where am i
okay there's that bunny that bunny keeps
showing whoa whoa whoa
hi ho [ __ ] okay you got pizza huh
favorite oh freak flavor
i don't know i don't i'm guessing oh
[ __ ] i'm guessing that's a clue
so left is probably the correct way but
i'm gonna go pepperoni
okay so i'm back here god damn it okay
where's the bunny you're that way so it
would suggest that that is leading me to
the
quote-unquote correct path if if i'm
right about that that's what it do and
that's what it's all about so the bunny
is right there do you trust me
no not not even remotely at all
okay so that's closing there
[Music]
so what happens if i go here
okay back here huh oh vent oh [ __ ]
i didn't know there was a vent here uh
whoa coin hey
yay i guess i should probably look
there's probably hiddens around here
everywhere i should probably look up
that guide again because i bet one of
the tapes is here too
i don't see the bunny wait a minute this
is the room for the other side
wait a minute this is the other side of
the room
that way oh yeah it does okay that's
so it is kind of logical okay so
i uh was
what the [ __ ] was that
what was that i've never seen that
before in my life
it was like a red smear with eyes
what was that oh god damn it how do i
keep getting back here
okay that goes there this goes here okay
so it's a set pattern it is not random
it is definitely not random
[Music]
it's definitely not random so what is
that what is that
what is that some weird red glowy freddy
i don't know got this okay this is fine
this is fine i believe it's this one
that one
correct yes okay we're here
uh there's some sodies there
and you go for the pizza which is fine
so
since you're on that side i'm guessing
that one
oh [ __ ] god damn it really
really okay all right
where does this one go again i don't
remember i'm just doing this so i can
have everything this goes all the way
back to five nights at freddy's one
okay so this one goes to here that one
goes to the three doors
this one goes to the elevator room
this one is out of order now well then
what do i
this way you trust me uh not really
okay not really how
i knew i shouldn't have trusted you okay
where does that lead
i don't know here all right good
whoa what the [ __ ] wait what wait what
the [ __ ]
that wasn't a door who [ __ ] what oh [ __ ]
um oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is there a secret here or something what
is this oh god um i don't see anything
so i'm just going to go
oh [ __ ] what goes up i don't know air
me i what are you talking about oh [ __ ]
are you kidding me oh god what goes up
oh
[ __ ] yes what goes up me
i go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
whoa oh
hi hi uh oh boy can i have this
you mind thank you what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] um oh [ __ ] high uh
okay you you two okay with that
whatever that was you all right with
that
okay just let me yeah i'm hungry i'm not
running and screaming
really did a number on me can i more of
this
okay happy birthday it's uh you how do
you know
it's my birthday is my birthday
okay good okay i guess i'll go here then
oh yes please oh [ __ ]
okay that's what the [ __ ] ladies and
gentlemen oh boys and girls
fazbear entertainment would like you to
put your hands together
for the one the
[Music]
no
what
[Music]
my
congratulations on completing the freddy
fazbear
virtual experience okay you did an
amazing job
thanks you might be wondering if you
missed anything or if there's anything
left to see
so just take my word for it you didn't
miss anything and there's nothing left
to see
what about that we're looking forward to
a fresh start with you
now that we've all had a good laugh at
these tall tales
and now that you realize that fazbear
entertainment is a safe
family-friendly brand with no skeletons
in our closet
so goodbye for now and we'll see you on
the toy aisle
okay bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye take care now bye bye
bye bye but
oh hi how are you doing there um
so uh
but but
i'm excuse me i'm just gonna be here
for a moment um take 15 you there
okay good hello privacy you don't know
me i don't
i'd created a series of logs for you
documenting the troubled development
of this vr game that you're now testing
in hopes that you
whoever you are and whatever team you
are with
will abandon development now i fear that
those logs
are being used as a trojan horse if
you're unable to abandon development
hide all traces of these logs that i've
created
i fear that finding them and
reassembling them
will also reassemble the very thing i've
tried so desperately to destroy
well you know it's a little late for
that um a little bit late
i can't can't really explain how futile
that is
now i don't have all of the tapes
there's nothing hiding behind here so um
little problem with that is that i've uh
that that came
last that came well second to last
anyway that wasn't quite last
um but
i'm still missing one tape
now where would a tape such as that
be is the question where would that be
gallery wait oh
oh oh
hello whoa yay thank you
okay disappointment that's that's great
um okay
uh is there
i think i remember here and there was
one here i'm gonna bonk my head aren't i
nothing there
okay nothing there um all right
uh anything behind this there's nothing
in here
definitely not oh well there we go
there she blows got all the tapes now uh
so that's
i don't know
hey oh wow that's a slow reload
okay hi this is great
i love that this is here
uh not sure what i'm supposed to
do with it this is horrible
this is a horrible peep show
we faster faster i can't go anymore
faster
faster maybe faster like i can
okay thank you for that what are those
wait what are those
wait what where were you in anywhere
what when were you anywhere when when
were you anywhere and what are you
when when were either of you anywhere
when were where were you where
were you where were you
i have no idea where were you it doesn't
make any sense
this doesn't make none sense
this is nonsensical there's a bunch of
nonsense
oh it's you little bit all right
whatever goodbye i'm going back the menu
i gotta assemble a rabbit apparently
hello
people hey who's got a tubby
[Music]
okay all right sorry my vision just
went awry one moment please
hello uh give me a second just gotta
real quick i gotta listen to this you
back there good okay here we go
there is a way to kill it it wants to
escape sure
to escape through someone great love
that someone plugged into this
wait hang on don't love it as much
that's you know uh wait
you have to let it begin the process of
leaving through you
then use the disconnect switch that i've
embedded by the main stage
let it approach you let it begin to
merge with you
play the music and flip the switch
that will cause a hard restart of the
game and flush the memory
effectively killing it okay i hope
i don't know when it will come for you
oh how about now
now right when i get out there probably
run immediately away
okay what happens if it merges with me
hello play the music huh
play the music huh
so is that the switch
is this the switch
huh at the price counter
minding my own business oh no i dropped
something
hope no one tries to merge with me
anybody here want to merge with me whoa
hi hello
hi how are you showtime stranger danger
hi hello may i merge with you
can you help me are you helpable
hello okay how about a nightmare land
would you like to
merge no
okay all right well okay in here maybe
hello okay not in here
weird um i don't know do i need to get
the coins or something whoa
[ __ ] hi okay hi uh oh you're submerging
huh
emerging huh well well well uh
how about is this the switch or is that
the switch showtime oh [ __ ]
um wait i didn't oh
[ __ ] uh i didn't i tried to
push wait
wait what what
oh hold on i didn't know which one i
wanted
oh the switch like as in that
oh like as in very clearly that's
uh yeah that makes a lot of sense okay
you know what actually that
that was my bad that was my bad oh hey
uh begin the process and flip the switch
flip the switch
what hi what the [ __ ] what was that
what happened did i do it i did it
didn't i i win
i'm good okay i don't know why that
the [ __ ] was that hello hi um
okay so i'm missing something here i
accidentally went into nightmare mode
flip the switch what does that mean
flip the switch
uh price counter this one
get out get in maybe i'm doing it too
early
i think i must be doing a little a hair
too early so i gotta wait until the
process starts and then flip it
i'm a good switch flipper i just got a
switch flip at the right mome
okay now oh no you're tricky you're
tricky but you're not going to trick me
that good
because i'm coming right back for you
here we go
merge nope okay well that's not fun
or fair okay you're there
so it's starting the process right about
there right there
oh oh whoa ah god
glitch um okay oh
oh hi hello how are you
uh you i was gonna be quiet is it
because i shot all the time
uh where are you going where you going
bubba uh what
wait whoa what the [ __ ]
hi um okay
uh hello are you she's gonna be there
not dream world are you oh hi hey
it's me with the melty eyes
shouldn't have taken all that lsd huh
well i mean it was kind of forcibly
injected into me and all that food i ate
wait the food i ate yeah i've been
reaching
my code into you
so what do i what do i do about this
there's something i can do about this
showtime prize counter
there's something i can do about you put
you in the lost and found doinkus
[Music]
please don't put me back in there oh
yeah after all you've done
after all the people you've probably
killed but i haven't killed
anybody oh yeah well you're not going to
kill me
what do i do with this what do i do with
you
now what why is there like an
incinerator or something all right you
know just to say i did
because i feel like i must uh
i'm going to definitively
i'm going to definitively go through
everything again
check very closely and make sure i've
got all of these things
here because if i don't like
i want to make sure i do let's just go
through them again i guess all right fn
f1 there's three in fnaf one so what i
need from that one
is to find the three ghost coins i don't
leave until i find
the ghost coins to know that i've got
them you know what i mean
so there was one under the cupcake
that's a ghost coin okay there's one in
here-ish
one there one in here yeah there there's
another one that's a ghost coin
okay got those and then one appears
sometimes in that monitor there oh there
it goes okay so there's that
um but i got them okay so those are
already got it
oh hey there we go yeah and i know i've
gotten the puppet one so i'm good here
how did i forget that one oh man okay
well that was
one i only there's only how many are
missing um
there's only two more so there's only
two more i'm only missing two more i
somehow stupidly missed that one um
oh my god are you kidding me are you
kidding me
oh my god i know i've gotten that one
what the [ __ ] how did i miss these the
one behind the head i know that that's
there
is there another one oh my oh my god oh
my god
hey listen you know what actually come
give me a hug
all right cool this is great holy [ __ ] i
got all of them okay uh whoa
whoa whoa hang on
oh hell yeah oh hell yeah um
what the [ __ ] ah hang on whoa uh we
gotta pick up my scraps
this sweet delicious butter ah the wall
uh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what'd that do what what the [ __ ]
what
whoa wait a minute okay um hang on a
second um
[ __ ] um yeah yeah [ __ ]
um what does that do
what the [ __ ] does that do
i don't just don't make me solve a
puzzle and then give me another mystery
oh [ __ ] okay um wow i don't know
what that means okay uh i don't know
[Music]
what this is for but i think that i
think that's it
i mean that's all i can think of to do
there's probably another secret to
unlock farther in the game but i don't
know what that is so for now
that's it that's the end of five nights
at freddy's vr
help wanted an amazing game
really honestly not just an amazing vr
game not just an amazing five nights at
freddy's game
but really fun like i mean the mystery i
wish it was
better solved but i guess people feel
the same way about
some of my videos so uh it's it was
really fun like a lot of fun i always
looked forward to playing this game
because of how much fun i was having so
thank you
everybody so much for watching uh if
there's a deeper mystery there let me
know down in the comments below and if
it's worth it i might revisit it but for
now
this is the end and it it's kind of
serendipitous
because it's also the end of my time
here in austin texas we finished
filming the big project actually today
is the big wrap party that we have so
just thank you everybody so much for
watching uh thank you scott kaufman for
making such a cool game and uh the team
that
made it i think steel wool studios uh
just thanking everybody for being
a part of it and really expanding the uh
five nights at freddy's universe in a
cool way
and uh thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoyed it let me know
what you thought down the comments below
check out the other five nights at
freddy's videos i've got linked in the
description or in the suggested videos
down there
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you